uh yeah it was probably influenced the
name and i guess with blue being kind of
the dominant brand color it's hard for
me to say that there was no influence
whatsoever well you know also brad when
he was at yale uh started a
startup at yale called go across campus
i did not know that yeah gaming really i
didn't know that i almost got bought by
zynga but uh almost brad didn't believe
in facebook as a gaming platform why
would you want to play games on facebook
i know
uh
so
so first of all i'm honored i'm honored
to leave these this discussion with you
guys um for a couple of reasons uh one i
think general assembly first who here
has heard of general assembly
okay so a testament to the strength of
the brand that um that
these two guys and their other and their
team have built it's particularly
special for me because uh about three
years ago when i started cross campus uh
the the mission was to provide a work
environment
a community and an education curriculum
for creative professionals startups and
entrepreneurs
and i modeled a lot of what we did on
general assembly they were this new york
company that was building an amazing
brand really quickly they were very
intentional about everything from their
their space design to the way they
communicated the words they used the the
images
and um and so it inspired me and drove a
lot of how we we kind of thought about
the business early on
uh
we launched about two years ago
about six months into it
we realized something we realized that
education was really really hard
it was really hard to do right
customer acquisition is tough getting
butts and seats uh
you know developing a strong curriculum
defending that curriculum finding people
to teach that curriculum and we
ultimately pivoted and said look we're
going to build our business on work
environment community and events
and events has become a critical part of
our business our our flagship santa
monica location is is a really a
community hub due to those events that
kevin mentioned we're raising money now
we're trying to expand into other
locations throughout la and hopefully
further
now going back uh so
we we kind of i don't know if i'd call
it a pivot but we realized education was
hard let's not we tried it we tried to
run some classes uh and then
about three months after we realized
that
we i i read that general assembly is
undergoing their own pivot and we'll
discuss whether that was a pivot but
they said you know what we've built this
great work environment in new york
that's a community hub but that's not
the business we're interested in we're
going full-on with education and you
guys raised like six seven million
dollars in that round
so it led you know the first thought is
obviously what did i miss here but
once that kind of thought faded away i
realized well you know what
they understand how hard it is and
they're executing well
uh talk about that a little bit yeah so
first of all i would say it was not a
pivot
you know
the funny thing is when you launch with
something in this world like everybody's
got such a short attention span and they
sort of whatever that first sort of
thing they they understand you as sort
of becomes that because you are
successful at the environment so when
you're successful something you say
we're not going to do that so the funny
thing is from the moment we launched the
space and we love that space we love the
startups that were in it we've had tons
of successful startups come out of it um
but we the minute we launched it we
realized okay we need to find something
else to do with this because as we
thought about what success would be then
again we had four co-founders three of
them went to yale and we we needed
growth to sort of support that that
overhead um at the time this was just a
little cash flow positive real estate
project like like what you're doing
really smart it's great for it's a great
business um and so we started looking
for growth we just didn't want to sign
about you know a million square feet of
leases or anything like that you know i
had just been working in private equity
equity during the last financial crisis
and i saw what happens when you take too
much long-term liabilities and try to
offset that with short-term revenue and
so we started looking for other ways to
kind of supplement what we were doing
and experiment before we really thought
what was actually going to happen was
that we were going to move off and do
our own startups so we started offering
um classes uh brad really was running
that program at the time and just trying
to see what would have happened if we
like think in a class called the history
of the internet we like had an out
arrangement with seed round
we had uh you know why you should use
nosql database structures and these were
all like short one-hour classes you guys
were trying a lot of different things
just throwing stuff at the wall and and
to our surprise it just kept working um
and it definitely was a moment in time
because i think you're right it's
incredibly hard and we just didn't learn
it was incredibly hard till it was too
late he had already committed to it
right now you raised um so that race was
like what six seven million dollars uh
so we raised four million
eleven so by that point we were
completely educational education maveron
lead which is amazing venture capital
firm uh sort of backed by howard schultz
um but we had other great investors
involved um jeff bezos yuri milner
all sort of you know behind this idea of
building this sort of global community
of individuals of power to pursue work
that they love physical campuses so then
you raise that money you open up uh what
was your second city outside of new york
uh london london was before san
francisco
yeah okay we wanted to be international
from the start we thought it was really
it was incredibly important to build
that international brand and not just be
pigeonholed into tech i gotta ask is
that why yuri milner was interested is
so okay so you build you build you build
a lot in campus um you show that you can
replicate the success overseas then you
raised another round it was
we raised uh our series b was 10 million
10 million and then uh so the mission
here again is the scale so just to give
the audience an idea of the scale here
over 100 000 students have come through
your programs
nine campuses physical campuses around
the world roughly uh an online education
business and then you're offering
education education in other cities
through partnerships
i hate describing the history of general
assembly
um because we really started doing this
this first inflection point was when we
started doing really transformative
education which was
not just one of the classes one of the
classes is how we started but around six
months later this was i remember jake
and i in front of a whiteboard saying
like okay we're going to do this for
real we need to make this transition
from just like hey i want to come and
learn like an hour's worth of javascript
to
i want to can people hear me by the way
yeah okay so there were some notes
volume up a little bit thank you
or closer oh wow yeah these mics are
super sensitive all right um cool so we
uh we pivoted from net not pivoted sorry
that was refined no that was actually
going from classes and workshops to
courses like
that is that's the closest i think we've
ever come
to
saying like okay this business is nice
but like there's this other big thing
that's much more impactful to the
mission of this company and that is
going
to these 12-week transformative programs
teaching things like web development
user experience design digital marketing
product management so that was a real
inflection point of ga is when we
decided to like you know these classes
and workshops are are fine but it's
really these transformative programs
that are going to empower people to
pursue work they love uh where the real
opportunity is yeah and i i would say
that that you know with that sort of
came this thesis that i think was very
relevant to today's conversation which
is that you know we speak all id grads
like i mean we i at very different times
uh brad and i went to yale but like you
know had very similar experiences that
you know liberal arts is at the core of
our american educational system and it's
incredibly important we all come from it
we can't really knock it it's amazing
our entire country and really most of
the developed world is based on it
teaches you how to think basically well
that's that's the conventional wisdom i
think a lot of things can teach you how
to think though so i think we should be
wary of that as the value proposition of
liberal arts but i think it's just sort
of how we've built the value system
around what education is and why it's
important
and so the problem with liberal arts is
that those institutions for the most
part um are not really set up in a way
to deliver sort of just-in-time
practical skills to help those students
be competitive
the minute they sort of hit the ground
running in the economy especially this
21st century economy where the
expectation is that employees can add
tactical value on day one and so we want
to be a complement to that system um by
providing these sort of just-in-time
skills do it in the context of a
community a global community of people
who all sort of share those same
aspirations and vision for their future
and then use those two elements to
really provide new opportunities and
on-ramps for people who want to uh be
able to sort of start a new career or up
level up their career trajectory in
technology business and design okay so
okay so now
i'm not i'm not checking text messages
i'm actually reading something here
speaking speaking for la and probably
other markets
your mission has become more broad and
more um
i don't know what the word is but but
it's not just about the classes you
you're placing you're helping people
find jobs you're continuing to work with
them in the long term uh i'm going to
read something from the blog post you
wrote when you uh just recently uh when
you've closed your series c financing so
apologize for going back to financing
but
so general assembly raised a very
healthy 35 million round it was led by
ivp
obviously one of the most
vcs in the industry
mavron participated others
and you wrote
our mandate our deepest organizational
responsibility is to support these
alumni not just now but for many many
years to come it is this obligation that
led to our new round of funding for
general assembly designed to ensure that
we will be able to educate students and
help decades of alumni yet to come
i thought this was interesting the tone
was interesting it didn't read the way
you would expect you know we've raised
35 million
we're going to scale from 9 to 20
campuses we're going to grow our online
business it was it sounded more like we
want to build a yale we want to build a
venerable educational institution over
the next 75 to 100 years am i reading
into it too much or
is that pretty accurate
no in fact i'm really glad you brought
that up because that is really sort of
how we think about ga well you told me
to bring it up
so
so you know and and i i would say we
don't really talk in terms of we want to
build a yale because yama's friendly
been around for 300 years and and we
admire that greatly um and
and we don't really talk about
disrupting something like yale because i
just don't think that's ever going to
happen but at the same time i think we
look at institutions that have been
around a long time and said what makes
that work right i mean yale has gone
through countless transformations over
the centuries in terms of the value
proposition to the students to the
funders how it's funded all this stuff
but sort of has stayed true to some core
mission throughout that entire life and
and when you start building a big
company i mean
when you get to kind of the series c and
if you're not really just in it for the
quick flip you start asking yourself
questions about how do you how do you
build an organization that can stand the
test of time and the answer is really is
is there's only one thing you can really
think about which is your state your
core stakeholders which is an archaic
our students our alumni and the same way
that yale cares a bunch about their
alumni because that's how they build
buildings and fund those buildings and
fun scholarships and things like that we
care about our website for a little
different purpose which is that that
becomes the core value proposition of
coming to general assembly over the long
run is that we want to build a global
community of people who are empowered to
pursue work they love and that truly
means you have to people not just all
starting out in a career but over time
this will be people with different
stages of their career except for
they'll all be focused on design
technology and business in hopefully the
most upwardly mobile sort of arc of
their career in the most dynamic cities
around the world
what does that mean for the i mean i get
that that's the vision what does that
mean for the business model monetization
you know the active on the ground stuff
where do you guys grow the business
and i would say that like the thing
about wow i just figured out found the
sweet spot it's nice um so
uh i would say that at the end of the
day
we
we look at what we're building at ga as
an organization with a vision and a
mission we have a brand that stands for
our values
and um the business
uh will is actually already multiple
businesses as you can tell by the fact
that we were in real estate we did
courses we did classes we do executive
education um we do a lot of support
services for our alumni um my guess is
that will only grow in what we do um and
our goal is to just continue to provide
products services and opportunities for
our stakeholders that sort of fit with
that core vision of empowering people to
pursue work they love i i would say that
you can only
you can have many stakeholders but you
can only have one customer and a very
intentional decision we made early on is
that the student is our customer
and we do a lot to place that student
into positions and work with them to
make sure they meet the right companies
but we decided very early on that we
were not a recruiter that we were not
going to charge companies for access to
our students which is a decisional a lot
of our competitors have made different
decisions right you decided that you can
really only have one customer i mean you
create the engagement between companies
and your graduates by virtue of the
community and the events and all that
you just don't monetize directly because
we don't believe that monetization there
it serves the longer term mission of
building a global community right that
makes sense um all right so brad uh
you you wrote something uh a year or two
ago that i read
and it's a sound bite that i've probably
used dozens of times and i've never
given you credit so i'm now officially
giving you credit um
and what you what you wrote uh which
again i thought was was really
insightful was that
events
are the best way to demonstrate
authority in the market for someone
today whereas five ten years ago you
might have written a blog post
to demonstrate authority today you would
moderate a panel you host an event the
technology things like meetup things
like eventbrite are there to make it
easy and so you see more and more events
like this and actually across campus our
event business is poor to the business
again it generates brand
it we service community help but it's
customer acquisition and it's we don't
have to pay a dime for it in fact we
make money on it
is that and with general assembly you've
grown in i think in la and other markets
by
creating these events uh giving people a
taste of the product is that the
customer acquisition strategy are you
changing it are you adding to it
um where is it going all day i would say
just as much as
the community is part of the product and
it's part of that promise and value we
deliver to our students
it's also
a customer acquisition strategy because
we look at
we have a very viral product like we
have an incredibly viral product because
someone gets in a course
and their life is transformed and they
have a huge job on the other hand on the
other end and a new skill set they're
going to tell their entire
network they're going to post it on
linkedin they're going to tell their
friends and family
so we have a variant and people don't
realize this but it's an inherently
viral product in a lot of ways and
the
events and the the paraphernalia that
surrounds it and represents the
community is just a way of
reinforcing and manifesting that i think
of the events that we have kind of like
you know knights and maurice and things
like that it's it's it's part of the
atmosphere that both solidifies the
experience it makes it something you'll
remember but also welcomes new people
into that experience all the time and
lets people know sort of what you're
about right
um so now i took a i took a class but i
i took a course i took a data science
course you did i did awesome data
science you're an alumni i'm a normal
yeah that's amazing that means i have to
do whatever you want okay
wow
within reason and boundaries of the law
of course
um but uh
and so
one of the challenges i think with with
with what you're doing um and again this
is not easy is some things you can teach
in 12 weeks or in you know
front end front end design or product
marketing some things like data science
which is highly statistics oriented or
even
programming encoding it's harder to
teach
in that period of time
some of the things you know this just
maybe the format isn't ideal for
um
you know
talk about the challenges are you saying
that you you felt like it was it was
too too fast or advanced
i i got a lot out of the class because
i'm a statistics wong
so i love learning about machine
learning and i programmed when i was
younger but you know frankly when the
programming stuff came out i just went
to one of my cross-campus members who
was sitting next to me it was a 30-year
plus program and i just watched over his
show oh i see so you cheated that was a
that's a modern tradition and yeah
and maybe there's an opportunity there
to do buddy you know buddy or or you
know team
yeah so i mean
i would say as you see us grow we will
be finding new and better ways of
teaching everything i would say data
science is one of our more advanced
classes which always comes at a cost
because it makes it less accessible and
require people who have prerequisites
and that's why the admissions rate on
that course is very low
i would say in general you know our
vision is not you know people say like
how what can you teach in 12 weeks and
the reality is i mean we are all
lifelong learners that's what we will be
we are all on a journey from novice to
expert and then we do that again right
and again and so
the goal of general assembly is to give
people an on-ramp a moment of
accessibility where they can
uh
acquire enough skills in the context of
the community that those next
opportunities will be available that
maybe otherwise wouldn't be and so i
would think of what we do is more like
retrofitting or or sort of tooling up
the last mile of a skill set in order to
allow somebody to get that foot in the
door as opposed to sort of creating
experts overnight like that's just not a
real i don't think you know i was on an
expert in anything leaving you know and
i don't think you'll be an expert even
in data science leaving general assembly
unrealistic yeah but you'll be able to
sort of know enough to be dangerous and
if you want to go more if you want to do
it professionally there will be plenty
of people who'd be willing to hire you
right it certainly helps you get a job
correct uh so you talk about the journey
from novice to expert right let's talk
about the early parts of the journey
let's talk about yale uh so you were
involved in yei
i was not because uh yeah i didn't exist
and at the time i was not really
interested in business and
entrepreneurship i wanted to be a rock
star i just basically hung out with my
singing group and smoked a lot of pop
i did the uh the latter not the former i
was uh uh i was a part of do you
remember being k
of course b and k one of the uh
underground societies no longer exists
no yeah no longer exists so i was just
back i did find out the pundits still
exist okay cool uh okay so but when did
you but you were involved with the uh no
yeah in the early days in the early
years yeah both y and uh and yes so you
weren't interested in entrepreneurship
necessarily which is interesting
yeah that was the journey i had in my
20s sort of going through this
experience of graduating with that yale
degree you know like diplomas latin so i
figured it was like a magic harry potter
spell which is going to open doors
magically and i sort of had to go
through this process of being incredibly
lost and lonely
and in my career trying to find that
direction and i think that in a lot of
ways was the inspiration for at least my
contributions to general assembly right
and brad how about you so i was uh i was
a little bit of a different uh
on a different path i actually was very
interested in leadership in college i uh
i got my start my freshman year selling
uh selling candy buying anti-card
catalogs from yale reselling them on the
internet um which was uh which was super
fun to corner the antique catalog market
it's actually really interesting it's
like there's a there's a whole market of
people out there who
love the idea of buying this piece of
like american academic history um oh i
just found the sweet spot with the mic
too um
sorry for everyone who uh who could not
hear me for so long um so yeah so we we
we bought these card catalogs and these
pieces of american academic history and
uh and and resold them online
uh which was so still to this day some
of the most fun i've ever had in
business or entrepreneurship and then
one day
uh barry nailbuff uh i was talking to
him and he told me that i didn't have a
startup i had a job
and i was so demotivated by that that i
decided that i wanted to like find
something else and go raise a pile of
venture money because that's what that
must be what having a startup is when
you raise a pile of venture money that
means that means you have the startup
um so that's what i did and uh ran you
know rent uh we go across campus this
gaming company for uh about a year and a
half while i was in college and uh about
a year after and
told me ran into the ground
wow and so then you guys got together
and had the idea for uh for general
assembly
basically
yeah i mean it really came from a bunch
of different places uh so brad's
co-founder in both the cart catalog
antique company and go across campus was
that brimer who had just graduated from
yale and i met him at a yale
entrepreneur happy hour in new york city
and i was fascinated by this kid running
this event he was the one hosting it
and so spent a lot of time just trying
to understand you know i i was in my
early 30s you know i felt like i was
past my prime and i was really just
hustling for consulting work and i met
this kid i was like wow this is but then
he started talking about wanting to
build this clubhouse for entrepreneurs
in new york and he was looking at a
commercial lease and i was like whoa
buddy like commercial real estate is not
as simple as like getting an apartment
maybe you should come over and have some
beers with me and we'll model it out
we'll see if it'll work um that but his
persistence led to sort of us actually
looking at spaces he brought in brad at
the time who was his co-founder on every
other project
and then we met our our fourth
co-founder adam who um had been sort of
coming at it from a different angle of
learning to build a design incubator i'm
sort of
taking inspiration from ideo and so we
all kind of met and you can sort of feel
those forces kind of mixing together and
there was something in the magic of the
four of us that created what general
assembly is today so um
that's interesting to hear that um
i joined with a second guy who was a
real estate expert who's had the same
conversation with me said whoa well let
me let me help you analyze this and then
the third co-founder was had started uh
an accelerator
in la so maybe there's maybe that kind
of combination
is uh maybe it's more than just
serendipitous
i think we also all started our things
in sort of a moment in time when this
idea of an entrepreneurial ecosystem
started to get taken yeah and
the tip the generation previous in terms
of entrepreneurial ecosystem tended to
be relatively balkanized and pretty much
focused on
service providers who had something
financially to gain from sponsoring
stuff in the startup community it was
either lawyers or venture capitalists or
some poor accountants who sort of would
host these events and
and we wanted this sort of our original
idea was to build something that was
free of venture capital it's like we
didn't bet venture capital was sponsor
they didn't have special access we we
told them if they want to be part of it
they had to belong as a member just like
everybody else and so actually got a lot
of people who never used the space to
actually just pay us so they could come
to our events
they were the best kind of gym members
right they never came and frankly we've
we've taken we've taken that uh
and run with it and it's and it works
it's a good model of engagement you know
because i think we think the moment it
becomes an accelerator becomes a
different thing it's an investment
thesis absolutely and that's not the
same thing as a community
it's actually directly in opposition to
the idea of a community i think these
you have people who are there's an
inherent competition to it of like oh we
all want this money and uh you know i
think we were able to build something
bigger because we went away from that
let's talk about competition uh you guys
are growing a big business you're not
under the radar screen anymore you've
got folks like udemy and coursera
codeacademy you've got the uh the online
uh you know mbas and other online
programs um
where do you see competition coming from
well you know i think
you have to think about competition a
very different way in our space because
i mean if you look at i mean do we i
mean you know because we're we have such
school spirit we may consider harvard a
competitor to yale but are they really
right i mean there is room for a lot of
people providing that kind of value to
their stakeholders um
it's a very very very big market uh it's
not a first to market
that being said is there's it's
definitely been experience we've had
where the cat is out of the bag and
you know we certainly have a lot of
people who look at us and then think oh
all you need is a programmer in a room
and you have yourself a school
and uh
some of those guys are doing a great job
and you know we're you know we will look
at sort of doing stuff with those guys
you know as we get bigger but
i think you know
we'll see a lot of
this is now a very very very hot space
of just this idea of helping people
two-up for the modern economy and
i think there's a lot of room in it but
i think it'll be really interesting to
see how it plays out and
i'm just glad that you know we've got a
fortress of a balance sheet and a great
mission and a 300 person team of people
who are incredibly focused and believe
in what we're doing and i think it's
going to be a pretty fun ride the next
few years for us and also you mentioned
a few of the online players like udemy
and uh codecademy and coursera we love
those guys because they raise awareness
for the idea that these skills are
accessible and are not just simply the
purview of
wants and computer science majors and
however it is very very very challenging
for someone to actually go through a
transformative experience and come out
the other end with employable skills
on those services i mean the dropout
rates the completion rates are just
really tremendously bad
so then a lot of those people end up
coming to general assembly if they're
really serious and saying hey
you know i tried learning how to code
using
udemy code school whatever
i got interested in it but i kept
getting stuck and it was taking too long
i actually want to do this for real and
that is and that's really where we see a
lot of our students interesting and i
know some of them are moving into
physical in-person education as well not
just specifically online but again
that's going to present all the
challenges you guys face
you raise the series c you've got the
fortress the balance sheet jake as you
as you refer to it uh do you start
acquiring or looking at acquisitions at
some point
i mean i think any company at our size
starts to look at it i would say
in general the road ahead of us is
pretty clear and
we're very focused on just the stuff
that's really important to us right
providing
more and more value to our students and
our alumni
uh continuing to make more of the world
have access to what we can provide
and you know there's depth there will
always be moments where things might
make sense to buy but in general it's
this is a game of just every day doing
our
the words of jim collins our 20 mile
march
yeah how many cities are you in right
now um either with a cat uh you know i
always the number i always lose track
but uh so we could do okay so on the
east coast it's going to work down the
east coast it's boston new york dc we
just renounced atlanta on the west coast
it's we just announced seattle and we
have san francisco and los angeles then
we have hong kong sydney
and london overseas um there'll be a few
more so i don't what is it what did you
count it's a dozen that's 10. okay so
what is it what's it going to be a year
from now two years i mean does it get uh
i don't think you know i don't think
we're like mcdonald's right like we're
this is not a game of just more stores
or home depot or any of those kind of
things one test centers or coupling test
centers
it's it's you know i think there's a
certain diminishing returns to having
physical locations and i think you'll
see us be much more careful and tactical
as we go uh you know we want to be
places that are great cities that have
the opportunity to build their own
startup ecosystems and we love being
part of that but i think as
there's a certain point in which you
know if you really want to be part of
the general assembly community you could
probably just come to a city near you
and take our courses and then and we
don't know what that where that moment
is right
i doubt we'll see us triple our
yeah this is the next year yeah
one of the uh so we're we're in
fundraising mode raising money one of
the things that i find frustrating uh is
this question of well what's the exit
right particularly you talk to the angel
groups really traditional um not a cash
flow business you don't need an exit
look i'm trying i'm trying i'm focusing
are you even raising
money text yourself at the end of every
year what are you doing well we're still
not at the stage where we can fund out
of cash flows we still need capex to
expand and but but just alone just or
find something old dude who just left
really somebody exists
so i look at the capital structure
really creatively
anyway uh but this question of this
focus on what's the exit makes no sense
to me because i turn around and i say
look i'm trying to build a great
business look at how we've executed
constantly trying to refine the product
religiously
generated scale cash flows and this is
the response is great well what's the
exit
like you know the board will get to the
point where we can so it's very
important to understand that like when
you go into the world of venture capital
what brad did when he thought he wanted
to be a real startup right or what we
did once we took our series a is you are
making a deal with the devil and i
apologize for the venture capitalist the
room sorry they know that i think um
because
it and it's a it's a it's a good deal
for many people but it's still a deal
and there are trade-offs
um
those venture capitalists have limited
partners who have given them their money
with basically a blank check but it's
only for a limited period of time and
that limited period of time means that
at some point they have to give the
money back to their lp's and that means
that they would need money from you in
order to be able to give money back to
their lp's and thus creates the need for
an exit within
five years yeah although i do think that
if you're if you're building something
that's generating scalable cash flows
and has a good operational
infrastructure whether it's an acquirer
whether it's a pe firm like there will
be an acquisition or should you give
a dividend back to investors i don't
know pe funds don't pay the same kind of
multiples of the public market
okay uh let me open it up to the
audience anyone have any questions for
uh for jake and brad
i think michael bloomberg was recently
uh quoted as a uh it's not realistic to
expect everyone to learn how to code in
order to get a job
specifically said uh let's be real
estate coal miners are not going to
learn how to cut a program
and so you know we're going to try to
push everyone to this digital economy we
have to be sensitive about
education i guess so what do you what's
the general assembly's founder's
position on who can learn how to code
what's realistic awesome yes no not
everybody should learn how to code like
and and and i think we have to sell
there has sort of become a very hand
wavy kind of like movement of the people
that should say that if everybody learns
to code everybody will have jobs in the
future then well all this happy techno
utopia and it's not really the case like
there's a lot more going on so we love
coding i think coding is a great skill
especially right now it's
imminently employable there's a huge
shortage of them
in 10 years or even in five years that
that may sort of cycle out a little bit
and not to say that coding won't be in
demand but it may not be like you know
god can we just get our hands on as many
junior programmers as we can
so that's different than this other idea
which is that we should teach coding in
our schools teaching coding in our
schools to me is about two things it's
about literacy for what like how the
logic of our modern world works that's
awesome i also think
coding is an awesome way to teach
advanced math and it makes like the
experience of dance math and it's fun
instead of completely tedious like when
i learned to code i was like if i
had done this it would have actually
probably taken a math class at yale by
the time i got to yale i hated science
and math because of the way we taught it
in high school so coding is awesome as a
teaching tool it can also be an awesome
skill in the workforce but we at ga very
purposely teach ux design product
management digital marketing there'll be
more subjects coming along we're much
more focused on the entire sort of range
of skill sets that we think sort of make
up the biggest chunk of knowledge work
in the 21st century and we want to help
people get those skills and those
on-ramps to those opportunities and
actually i think victor your question is
a great one expand that same question
address it not just to coding but to
this to this whole subsets of
new economy information idea experience
economy type skills user experience
product marketing coding
do we want to do we want everyone to be
able to acquire these skills i mean are
there people do we need traditional
you know people who are doing other
stuff how do you where do you draw the
line you know do you feel like
it's offensive or threatening to more
traditional folks we still need
barbers and cosmetologists as well it's
just i don't think we're necessarily the
right people i don't know people people
could build machines to cut air i mean
do you want to stick your head on i mean
we are in tennis
right no we are in san francisco so we
can talk about like our robots gonna
come and rule us all and
maybe right but i think uh if you look
at that kind of that future has been
projected many times in you know in the
past
and i think
we you know i i'm actually on that
subject a big fan of jared lanier who's
sort of a philosopher and
and former entrepreneur who writes a lot
about how that future is not inevitable
like we as humans are in control of our
own destiny that way and so i think
there's lots of possibilities to think
about what we want the labor market to
look like and i would say i would the
other thing i would say is like like
yale i think ga is serving a very very
uh small overall portion of sort of a
whole sort of socioeconomic system and
we're okay with that like there will be
advanced manufacturing there will be 3d
printing there will be all sorts of
interesting service opportunities there
will be artists there will be you know
this is not about uh you know trying to
sort of build the people who are gonna
build the machines that will rule us off
this is about like an equality that's
always flops and people need to be have
more access to just-in-time training for
those skills
yeah
i think you i think you might be a
little bit too modest though and then in
terms of that slice thing small i think
that slice more so than at any time in
history is getting getting larger for
some very fundamental reasons we've got
a member across campus who builds
robotics for the largest printing
company in the country in the world
rather so when you order a book from
amazon it goes and it gets bound and
printed through these 50 million dollar
assembly lines of printing uh he goes
into plants uh he takes them from 300
employees to six
and sets up sensors and machines and
screens that say when the red
exclamation mark comes up pull this
lever and gets death threats and
it's not an accept i mean it's not the
exception that's happening especially
with the internet of things and the
hardware revolution um
so i i i hope for your sake that this
slice of uh new economy skills is a
growing slice
and i hope for our sake that not all the
workers in the world are are replaced
it would certainly create some
socioeconomic challenges uh any other
questions for brad and jake i guess if
not we can uh
one more over here
where do you see the upper level
education industry globally going in the
next decade or so given folks like
general assembly yeah and so um by
virtue of sort of where we citizen the
education innovation sort of cycle right
we get invited to a lot of these
conferences with a lot of more legacy
educational providers and i would say
um in general
we are definitely heading towards a
massive reckoning uh
yale's gonna be fine princeton's gonna
be fine nyu great you know probably a
lot of state schools sort of figure out
their own way but we you know that is a
small portion of like there's 4 600
colleges like four-year-old accredited
universities in the united states i
would guess that at least half of them
will probably face impending bankruptcy
within the next 15 years
um it's something that people don't talk
about or think about and and everybody's
in deep denial about it and that's not
going to be because of us it's going to
be because of
the online access you might have to nyu
why would you go to some random school
in the middle of the day or mit or
stanford or mit or stanford great
university now that being said i think
there's opportunities for those schools
that are smart and see the future to
create value because as much as stanford
and mit and yeah will put their content
online for free there's a reason that
those institutions are willing to put
their content online for free that they
know that people will still pay for it
because the value is not in the content
it's in the experience it's in the
alumni network it's in the in the sense
of being able to affiliate yourself with
this you know 300 year old brand and so
um it's just going to be a little bit of
a race at the bottom in terms of not
really those top tier schools but the
next year who wants to sort of go like
to you and start offering their program
to everybody and anybody around the
world who wants it you know who's going
to sort of try to sort of do the
mass-market higher-end approach brad any
thoughts on that
yeah i i think when we talk about higher
ed i mean there's a big association in
our minds because you know many of us
went to like really high-end schools the
fact is like there are a colossal number
of those 4 000 universities probably a
majority that really have no reason to
exist other than the fact that they're
accredited and they're accredited for
legacy reasons because it's very hard to
get accreditation it's very very very
hard to lose it
so the fact that you have all these
legacy institutions that are basically
existing upon their accreditation and
their accreditation alone i think where
that's where the reckoning is really
going to come yeah it's going to be fine
yeah and i would say that the thing that
gail has that i think is incredibly
special and i think as we think about
you know supporting our alma mater and
stuff like that is that these
world-class research institutions will
become not commodities as well because
there are certain places where those
10-year professors are being subsidized
by the undergraduate populations that
will disappear something like yale with
the billions and billions and billions
of endowment with preeminent scientists
will be able to really hold a torch for
what i think is like one of the most
important sort of time-honored uh
purposes of the university which is to
make sure that we're sort of preserving
and furthering knowledge for the next
generation that day of reckoning in
universities is that happening in europe
in other countries or is that a us
phenomenon
i know you probably haven't thought of
that as much
it's gonna happen in a very different
way because of us uh do other do other
countries have that density of just no
because they were much more because the
government got involved a lot sooner in
the payment and the funding of this
university so they kind of managed
capacity a little bit better um after
the after world war ii the gi bill sort
of
uh led to this massive explosion in
universities designed to really serve
all of those returning um soldiers and
veterans
and that kind of led to this what we
have now which is this legacy
infrastructure that's going to be
destroyed i would say that there's
somewhat of a unique cultural aspect as
well which is just as ten years ago
everyone needed to own their own home in
the united states and that wasn't really
a phenomenon that existed in a major way
in other countries you have the same
cultural implications around everyone
needs to get a four-year liberal arts
degree to be a functioning member of
american society i think that is going
to cause a greater distortion in the way
american and americans think about
education then there will be in other
countries where it's completely
legitimate to go to
a in germany say to go to a traditional
school followed by an apprenticeship
australia you're not going to see peter
thiel offer his fellowship in other
countries um
awesome uh thank you very much put your
hands together